back down to that breaking news story
from the very top of our show yeah a
construction incident causing some major
traffic back up let's get out to sasha
loftis who just arrived at the scene
sasha how does it look
denise and brian still pretty active
seen here right near eastern and the u.s
95 you can see the portion of the bridge
that is collapsed there with some tape
around it looks like some
caution tape surrounding that so this is
what we know from ndot so far they tell
us one ndot employee was hurt in this
situation no word on how serious those
injuries are this bridge was coming down
anyway we've been talking about the
demolition of this bridge for a little
while ago it's being demolished in a
controlled manner no word on
specifically what led to this person's
injury though if this bridge demolished
when it was or collapsed when it wasn't
supposed to rather we of course are
waiting for more details from ndot on
this as for traffic delays we're told
this part of eastern was shut down
anyway for this demolition so traffic
isn't affected any more than it normally
was this area has been closed since
monday again we're told one ndot worker
injured in this situation here this
bridge was being demolished at eastern
in the u.s 95 no word on how serious
those injuries are we are expecting to
hear from officials here shortly we will
of course bring you the latest both on
air and online reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now sasha thank
you more updates on 8newsnown.com ahead
in the newscast if you're looking to
rent an apartment in the valley you're
going to have to dig pretty deep into
the pockets we've got the latest prices
and a look at some of the other hot
spots across the country and the race